Кінець травня.
В учнів цієї школи у селищі Новгородське починаються канікули,
а у випускників - доросле життя.
Вчителі бажають їм гарного відпочинку, а головне - миру.
Адже Новгородське - прифронтове селище у центральному Донбасі.
До лінії зіткнення звідси - лише декілька кілометрів.
Тож припинення війни - найбільше бажання цих людей.
На нового президента тут великі сподівання.
Випускниця Аліна Пелих і її вчителька історії, директорка школи Любов Пилипенко,
не приховують - разом вболівали за Володимира Зеленського.
На нового президента, людину молоду, завзяту, ми сподіваємось, що оновиться Україна,
відродиться, розквітне і тут для нашої молоді, для наших випускників
буде місце, де вони знайдуть собі застосування.
Востаннє тут стріляли у жовтні 2018-го року,
каже директорка школи і показує нам місце, куди прилетіла куля.
Біля ось цих воріт. Діти у нас на уроці грали у футбол. Почали літати кулі, і прилетіла куля.
Якраз на воротах стояв хлопчик, і через його плече перелетіла і перед ним вдарила куля.
Це дуже страшно, коли поруч з тобою падають снаряди.
Ми питаємо директорку школи, як, на її думку, можна припинити війну.
Каже, сподівається на перемовини - передусім у нормандському форматі.
Головне - не із владою самопроголошених "ДНР" та "ЛНР".
Я не вважаю доцільним розмовляти зі злодіями.
Наразі у центрі Новгородського спокійно.
На перший погляд, селище живе звичайним життям робітничого донбаського містечка.
З типовими проблемами - від екології до безробіття і відтоку населення.
Проте на околицях роками триває воєнний стан.
На цю вулицю потрапити можна лише з дозволу військових.
Адже тут закінчується підконтрольна українському уряду територія.
До лінії розмежування? 50 метрів.
Майже кожного дня тут літають кулі. Супротивник - з трьох боків.
Там, там і там. Противник - близько 700 метрів звідсиля.
Люди тут живуть на межі - підконтрольної Україні і неконтрольованої території,
війни та миру, а часто - життя і смерті.
Ми намагаємось поговорити з місцевими.
Проте на військових і нашу камеру мешканці селища реагують знервовано -
від інтерв’ю навідріз відмовляються.
Без коментарів...
Не на камеру дехто з них каже - за п'ять років вже зневірились, що на їхній вулиці буде мир.
Не вірять і новому президенту. Сусідству з українськими військовими - зовсім не раді.
Звинувачують їх у своїх стражданнях. Військових таке ставлення засмучує.
Втім, визнає командир підрозділу, вдіяти нічого не можна - війна є війна.
Прийдуть сюди інші, то вони так само казатимуть: "Ви нам заважаєте".
Коли приходять будь-які військові, вони, природньо, заважають місцевому населенню.
Ми з розумінням ставимося до їхнього нерозуміння.
Командир батальйону погоджується показати нам передові позиції української армії.
Мікроавтобус, на якому ми туди їдемо, підрозділу декілька років тому подарували волонтери.
А ось цього "Москвича" - військові взагалі придбали за свої власні гроші.
Волонтерська допомога і досі важлива, розповідають бійці.
Втім, запевняють: із 2014-2015 роками сьогоднішню ситуацію порівнювати не можна.
Заслуга Порошенка в тому, що він відродив армію.
Під його керівництвом армія відродилась у найкоротші терміни.
Стосовно ж нового президента, Володимира Зеленського,
комбат, а у цивільному житті - гірничий інженер з Кривого Рогу, у прогнозах стриманий.
Каже - свого земляка судитиме по справах.
Почекаємо, подивимось.
Як кажуть, перші сто днів все покажуть.
Поки що ніхто не знає Зеленського як чоловіка, як президента, як верховного головнокомандувача.
Ніхто його не знає.
Армія - це просто інструмент в руках політиків.
Армія повинна бути поза політикою.
Якщо три четверті громадян вибрали його, то це вибір держави.
Ми побачимо, що буде. Очікувати - це очікувати.
Тільки вибрали. Тільки начав руководить державою. Побачимо, що буде.
Хоча на фронті останнім часом спокійніше, обстріли на ділянці - майже щодня.
Єдина війна в Європі, позиційна та архаїчна, триває.
В те, що вона скоро закінчиться, військові не вірять - як і в те, що варто домовлятись із Росією.
Можна домовитись з Росією - віддати їм нашу территорію вплоть до Ужгорода.
Як мінімум до Івана-Франківська. Домовимось з Росією, да. Віддамо все.
Станем вассальною державою, "ляжемо" под них.
Путін що казав? В Криму російських солдат немає. Його слова по телевізору.
Результат? А щодо нового президента - поживем, побачим. Хай працює.
До окупованої Горлівки звідси лише кілька кілометрів.
У бінокль чудово видно околиці міста. Втім, навпростець туди не потрапити.
Шлях до міста лежить через блокпости. Пункт пропуску Майорське виглядає, як справжній кордон.
Більшість з цих людей перетинають лінію фронту, щоб отримати пенсію
на підконтрольній уряду території або відвідати рідних, які живуть на іншому боці.
Питаємо їх, чого вони очікують від нового президента Володимира Зеленського.
Мені здається, він все-таки припинить війну.
У нього зовсім інші розмови. Той як хотів - тільки військовим шляхом забирати.
Молодий, енергійний. Час міняти старих.
Звісно, ми хотіли б знову бути разом, щоб не стояти у цьому натовпі. Щоб все було нормально.
І нехай кожен розмовляє своєю мовою.
Дуже важко розібратися, з ким сідати за стіл переговорів - з "ЛНР" та "ДНР" чи з Росією.
Напевно, насамперед з "ЛНР" та "ДНР". До чого тут у нас Росія?
Даю 80 відсотків, що він припинить війну. Він налаштований на те, щоб був мир.
Тількі прямі переговори - з Путіним.
Через Мінськ, якусь там Європу чи США вирішити нічого не вдасться.
Вони нам не допоможуть. Ми їм не потрібні.
Хоч якась надія. На Порошенка ніякої надії не було. Запропонувати федерацію.
В будь-якому випадку – тільки мирний шлях, не війна.
Один теж п’ять років обіцяв, що буде мир. П’ять років морочив нам голову.
Тепер інший буде морочити - невідомо, скільки років.
Я пам’ятаю, він казав: "Я зроблю так, щоб українці не плакали".
Я бажаю йому божої допомоги, щоб йому це вдалося.
Володимир Зеленський дав людям на Донбасі надію - насамперед, надію на припинення війни.
Проте погляди громадян на те, як цього досягти,
а також на майбутнє країни залишаються суперечливими -
навіть у цьому окремо взятому регіоні.
Чи вдасться новому президенту об'єднати країну не лише на електоральній мапі, а й в реальності -
стане ясно лише після того, коли він оприлюднить свою стратегію щодо Донбасу.